regardez-bien 14e manque on a peur on
n'a pas ouvert pour travailler
quelle tristesse autant on peut
comprendre qu'on est fermé au vu de la
hausse de l'activité des mines mais ce
manque de visibilité pour un
entrepreneur cctv
[Musique]
les barreaux et est ouvert on est restés
fermés on nous a traités de non
essentielle
en fait il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont accumulés la colère elle est
effective et présentait bien évidemment
tout le monde pas la dynamisation et ne
couvre absolument pas les pertes connais
mon cas je cumule les miennes et coup
seulement trois mois trois mois sur 14
mois c'est une honte
[Musique]
ça a été un moment dur parce qu'au final
on a tapé sur les économies tout ça et
c'est vrai que comme on voit pas le bout
on sait pas trop où on va
[Musique]